the variable by itself when you solve an
algebra equation you're going to try and
get the trig function by itself so what
we're going to do is we're going to
subtract one from both sides we're going
to divide by two so now you have sine of
x equals negative 1/2 so we're on the
unit circle does sine equal negative 1/2
well you can see it's going to be here
and there so it's going to be at 7 PI
over 6 and 11 PI over 6 now if they
asking the question you know what are
the solutions between 0 & 2 pi
this is all you would have to list but
if it says give a general solution what
you're going to want to do is you're
going to want to add 11 PI over 6 plus 2
pi n okay plus 2 pi and that means that
if you're here if you add an additional
2 pi or multiples of 2 pi you're gonna
go around the circle you're gonna end up
in the same spot and sine will be
negative 1/2 same thing with 7 PI over 6
you could say 7 PI over 6 plus 2 pi and
and that just means if you're here if
you add 2 pi you'll be here if you add 2
times 2 pi you're going around twice
you'll end up in the same spot on that
circle the sine value will still be
negative 1/2 so that's one example let's
take a look at the next example the next
example we have 4 cosine squared X minus
1 equals 0 again we're going to try to
get that trig function by itself so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to add 1 ok
then we're gonna divide by 4 because
we're trying to get the cosine by itself
here so divide by 4 those cancel divide
by 4 okay now what we're gonna do is
we're going to take the square root of
cosine squared and the square root of
1/4 if you want to take the square root
of both sides to keep it balanced when
you take the square root how many
solutions do you get two rights plus or
minus so square root of 1 is 1 the
square root of 4 is 2 and the square and
the square root these are inverses of
each other they're gonna cancel one
another out so we just end up with
cosine of X you
plus or minus a half so again we're
going to go to the unit circle look at
where cosine equals positive 1/2 or
negative 1/2 and that's going to be here
at this point and here for positive 1/2
and then negative 1/2 we're going to be
here and we're going to be here so if
you wanted to list your solutions you
could just say this is over here at PI
over 3 2 PI over 3
4 PI over 3 and 5 PI over 3 if you need
to review the unit circle take a look at
the video I did on the unit circle to
get some more insights on how to solve
for these points these angles but what I
want to know make a note of here is that
see how the PI over 3 and the 4 PI over
3 see how they're diametrically opposed
or like across from each other like 180
degrees apart same thing with 2 PI over
3 and 5 PI over 3 so if they ask for a
general solution what you can do is you
can group these together as a pair the
ones that are across from each other by
saying PI over 3 okay so let's write
that down over here PI over 3 plus PI ad
because PI remember is 180 degrees
you're just going halfway around the
circle you'll end up at 4 PI over 3 if
you add another PI you'll end up back at
PI over 3 so by starting at PI over 3
and adding multiples of pi you'll keep
ending up at one of these two points
where cosine is 1/2 or negative 1/2
same thing with 2 PI over 3 and 5 PI
over 3 so 2 PI over 3 plus 1 PI ad
that'll take you from here to here
another PI will take you back to here
and so on and so this is how you can
write a general solution if it just says
from 0 to 2 pi just list these each once
and that'll be that'll be perfect okay
let's go over here to this problem next
again drawing the parallel between what
we did in algebra 2 what we're doing
here with solving trigonometric
equations this looks like a quadratic
equation you've got a squared term a
linear term a constant term here we're
gonna do is we're gonna factor the
trinomial into two binomials so let's do
that
we've got to sign X and one sign X those
multiply to 2 sine squared X over here
positive 1 and positive 1 those are
going to multiply to 1 but the inner
product in the outer product 1 sine X
and 2 sine X add up to our middle term 3
sine X now that we factored it let's set
both of the factors equal to 0 that's
the zero product property and let's
solve so if we do that we're going to
get sine of X equals negative 1/2 I just
subtracted 1 and divided by 2 and here
we're going to subtract 1 we get sine of
X equals negative 1 again we're going to
go to our unit circle we're two sine
equal negative 1/2 and where does it
equal negative 1 sine is negative 1 here
sine is negative 1/2 here and here so
you're looking at these three locations
that's going to be 7 PI over 6 11 PI
over 6 and 3 PI over 2 and if you want
to write as a general solution you can
do it like we do these ones over here
this problem what I want to point out is
this is a multiple angle all these other
problems we were just working with One X
say here we're working with the Reax so
what we can do in this problem is treat
this like a group like a chunk just ask
ourselves where does tangent equal 1 so
on the unit circle tangent equals 1 here
and here okay so at PI over 4 and 5 PI
over 4 we can write this as a general
equation by saying PI over 4 plus PI n
so PI over 4 plus multiples of Pi will
take you from this point to this point
and so on okay but that's not what x
equals that's what 3x equals okay so
what we want to do here is want to
divide everything by 3 to solve just for
one X so let's do that we're going to
divide everything by 3 and we get x
equals PI over 12 plus PI over 3 times
ad
so this is a general solution if it just
asks what are the solutions from 0 to
2pi once around the circle here you can
start off by put making n 0 1 2 3 4
until you exceed 2 pi then you know okay
just just going to be those angles the
other way to do this and this is house